island nation leaders are calling cop 26
a make or break moment for their
survival now they want at least half of
the promise 100 billion dollars a year
in climate funding from rich countries
to go directly to adaptation measures
now only a quarter is currently
allocated to it and the most vulnerable
countries in the world say that will be
too little and it's rapidly becoming too
late so mikhail i don't know if you know
but we've lost a michael mann he dropped
out behind me there while i was
introducing you but hopefully we'll get
in back in a moment but first of all so
this call from these climate vulnerable
nations these island states saying that
cop 26 is make or break for them
what do you think it's going to be is it
going to be make or break will the rich
nation step up and give them the help
they need
when we look in the eyes of small island
states leaders we are looking at the eye
of climate change and first of all
there's a moral imperative to make that
happen and i think cop 26 is an
excellent uh opportunity for world
leaders to do that and to uh understand
that this is it
now this is it because climate change is
not something that's happening in 2030
or in 2013 hour in 2050 climate change
is already here and has already been
here for small island states as we've
seen
uh in your excellent piece about granada
um the climate finance it has been
promised uh as a um
as we know is completely insufficient to
meet the adaptation needs of those uh
small island states
and in a way it is almost like choosing
between a vaccine and a treatment if we
start weighing off adaptation versus
mitigation
climate change uh is already impacting
those countries in a way that is
irreversible for some of them
but i think that we have an interesting
opportunity here because small island
states have proved in the past
especially around the paris agreement
that they have significant power to
impact those debates well yes okay they
were the one they were the ones who
spearheaded for example the crucial
language on well below two degrees that
um managed to get into the paris
agreement uh and spearheaded an
excellent ambition and advanced debate
on loss and damage i'm just going to cut
in because we've got michael backs we
want to celebrate that by by bringing
him in i'm sorry we lost you just for a
moment there michael but let's pick up
on that point that mikhail was making
there that
nations like the marshall islands made a
real difference didn't they around the
paris agreement by by stepping up
putting pressure on at just the right
time could that happen again this time
round and how much power do those
smaller nations have in negotiations
like this
well they've got the power of their
voice um and and they have to tell the
stories um people have to understand
that you know when we talk about
dangerous climate change being at a
degree and a half celsius or two degrees
celsius dangerous climate change has
arrived for these people um if you're
one of the caribbean islands if you're
puerto rico it was devastated by
this monster storm hurricane maria
just a few years ago they are feeling
the dangerous impacts of climate change
now and they can't wait any longer and
unfortunately they have the least
resources
and they've had the least role in
creating this problem in the first place
and so there's really an ethical
obligation on the part of the industrial
countries of the world that really
fundamentally created this problem in
the first place to provide all the
assistance that they can to them and and
these countries they need to use their
voice the moral authority of the stories
that they can tell about the
you know the truly devastating impacts
that they are now seeing
to wake us all up and to put pressure on
our policymakers to act now and michael
very briefly how much of the changes are
already locked in for these islands
well you know i i like to i'll often
take sort of doomists to task for
overstating you know the the the the
challenge that we face for you know um
for presenting climate change as an
unsolvable problem um
something that will lead to our
extinction but you know it's hard to be
too optimistic with some of these
low-lying island nations they really are
facing an existential crisis they will
lose their homes they will lose
everything they have and so some of that
is locked in it's baked in there's a
certain amount of additional sea level
rise that's baked in if we can hold
warming to one and a half degrees
celsius which is we already saw earlier
we heard we need to bring carbon
emissions down by 50 within this decade
but if we can do that we can probably
hold warming below one and a half
degrees celsius probably limit sea level
rise to under a meter where there's
still the potential to adapt to those
impacts
you